I reject nation it's Greg Alva here and
I'm John Humphrey guys mark hamill
regrets sharing his last Jedi opinions
in public I wonder why we did a whole
video commenting on it yeah we did
reaction to the interview itself reset
it I was cringing watching that video I
mean I'm not in the thick of the last
Jedi debate you know out on everywhere I
know this is the one time I I sort of
count myself lucky that I'm not like
fanatical about Star Wars because like
this is tearing up lives from Mark
Hamill to come out and be like yeah I
had some reservations about to I was
like well here's what he said I regret
voicing my doubts and insecurities in
public creative differences or a common
elements of any project but usually
remain private all I wanted was to make
a good movie I got more than that Rian
Johnson made an all-time great one
humbled Hamill because he's Mark Hamill
but now he's being humble and sitting
down I've had trouble accepting what he
saw for Luke but again I mean I have to
say I haven't seen the movie I was wrong
I think being pushed out of your comfort
zone is a good thing because if I was
just another benevolent Jedi training
Padawans we've seen it we have well seen
it happen you know in other films
because wasn't obi-wan like wasn't Ewan
McGregor like yeah you don't really see
Anakin get trained I thought about it a
little bit later my furry shot the video
for the other one obi-wan retreats the
Tatooine
after everything falls apart with Anakin
and he's there for years it makes sense
that Luke yeah when they make a huge
mistake or like they fail to have
foresight on something or they're
disappointed or whatever they go off and
reflect for ever in this one seems to be
a pattern that occurs in with Jedi and I
respected the last Jedi because
script when Luke is pointing out about
Darth Sidious and how the Jedi fail a
lot of the time like he was looking at
the track or the Jedi Luke Skywalker or
the character I respected that because
I'm like yeah this choice for Luke makes
total sense so I didn't disagree with it
um it's later and the universe is
changing and the the concept of the Jedi
and the force is kind of changing and
and I do think that that's a good note
that he touched on is that you know it's
good to be pushed out of your comfort
zone and a lot of the analysis I've seen
about the last Jedi is about that theme
in general about shifting toward the new
you know breaking out of the old ways in
regards to Mark Hamill say this so
clearing the air I mean what's your take
on it do you think he means that or do
you think because when I saw that
interview I was like he seems very
passionate on his disagreement and this
is also um promoting the movie interview
this is movies already been made for him
that seems so passionate about the
disagreement and the tough cuz it's one
thing to read these words like we're
reading quotes from an interview we're
not we didn't actually hear it I feel
like I might have a different response
to this if I was hearing him say it yeah
but when you when you hear a
disagreement in tone that strongly it
makes me go he must still feel that way
this to me kind of sounds like saving
his ass or not trying to offend the
people he worked with or a fan Rian
Johnson or you know still him odds if
you come back as a force ghost effecting
the fire that is raging is we want the
movie to do well we don't want to have a
bad reputation we figure contribute like
it's not bad that people were kind of
divided but if you are the goose you're
the meat stars yeah I don't think that
this is devoid of those concerns like
this doesn't seem like he was just like
oh you know what man I was I messed up I
feel it kind of 50/50 on it there is
kind of a genuine push toward you no no
no I the film is still great like you
know I'm sure that that's an authentic
feeling because he does a great job and
you can tell he gave his all to this
movie yeah that's that's honestly the
saving grace of when I read this like
this could be a PR move or this could be
him just really feeling like he has to
clear up everything the reason why I can
believe he's just clearing up
because it doesn't want to be
miscommunicated he doesn't like the film
is because he does such a great job in
the movie that it would be very hard for
me to believe that he doesn't like the
movie when like the big reception to
especially is the praising his
performance specifically yeah he's in it
and and that's that's the OP the other
side of that coin is I feel like part of
it is because you know hee hee dizzy
turn in a great performance and part of
it too as I imagine he doesn't want to
be at the forefront of the people who he
doesn't want to be the even Laura
Campbell says because that's just not
the position well even mark hamill says
that's not Luke is gonna be a much
bigger thing people here more than yes
more people will have heard that and has
done a lot of those people will not have
heard this yeah so to a degree I feel
like this is in response to that being
like I have to kind of cool that jet
because that is a big deal if Mark
Hamill's like yeah I really know about
the interpretation of Luke either's but
if that's a big issue people are
debating with this film like I can
definitely see why he would have the
desire to come out if this came from him
directly if this wasn't somebody
encouraging him to say this and at the
same time I think in terms of clearing
it up when he's in the interview he was
specifically touching on pre-production
stage he was specifically touching on
prepping for the role getting ready to
shoot the movie his thoughts and
feelings at that time in that interview
he we didn't really see him elaborate on
after he saw the final product and in
this quote he's talking about after he
saw the movie he realized oh I was wrong
I see exactly why Rian Johnson wanted to
be this way yeah for sure
yeah I don't I don't feel like those
original feelings are necessarily gone
but I do think that the reaction is not
what he intended yes is an attempt to
corral that yeah alright guys well you
believe Mark Hamill do you think it was
just a PR move to save his own ass what
do you think it was comment below
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bell you could Dow it and
follow the us and the deaf you could
download and follow us on the Stardust
app at the real rejects follow us first
people and also check out our patreon
it's like a second YouTube channel over
there I got a lot of exclusive video
posts